let's go next i'm told that scottish
scott from scotland has fixed his
problems
scottish scott you're back what's going
on
hey david can you hear me yes i can
oh fantastic yeah sorry about that i
just um saw your video on youtube and so
i had to download this card again and
uh get off and running and yeah i wasn't
quite used to getting it to work and
didn't know how to unmute myself are you
sure you're really scottish
what makes you say that no i'm kidding
i'm kidding go ahead what's on your mind
that obviously
um
yeah i'm just really looking forward to
the
uh the final hearing of the january 6th
committee tomorrow i just wondered what
you're thinking and anticipation of like
who's going to be there what sort of
testimony we might expect and how the
trump is at large might
sort of respond to it well unfortunately
because this is the friday show that
hearing was last night and i know that
you've been in a coma for 48 hours so
you wouldn't know that
but um i believe what happened slash is
expected is that uh donald trump's
former deputy national security adviser
will testify donald trump's attorney a
white house attorney pat sipoloni is
expected slash did testify uh i i am
looking forward to slash really enjoyed
it last night if you understand what i'm
saying
uh yeah yes um let's just say that all
the
tv wires melted yesterday due to all the
things that we're experiencing in the uk
just now well anyway isn't it like three
days earlier in scotland or something
like that
three days earlier yeah that's why you
just haven't gotten the hearing yet
uh yeah yeah we're actually time
traveling i can see into your future
and
you made a video earlier about the um
what was it again the the
reaction from trump's supporters if he
actually does become indicted uh by
merrick garland or whomever um and
if i remember correctly you thought that
the there could potentially be among his
strongest cult followers uh a really
strong violent reaction yes um
i i'm not so sure i think
i think yes there will be a certain
violent reaction but in terms of like
mass protests of thousands of people all
gathering together i just get the
impression that a they're
too shattered shrapnel i should say at
the moment and they're just too far
spread and
they can't organize themselves well
enough and b
i don't know just
do you think they're that far gone that
if
he were to be indicted
people would see that as
oh they're they're lying it's fake news
etc or would that almost be like a
wake-up call for a lot of his own spring
no the cultists would say that it's all
a political witch hunt they they would
say this is an outrage and we i think
you're right they wouldn't do like mass
peaceful protests you would just have
these small violent cells going
completely berserk uh scott i i gotta
run i appreciate the call and hearing
about all of it
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read one thing
i do not have time to add to what i'm
reading in paper form is more history
but i want to know about history and
that's where our sponsor blinkist comes
in blinkist doesn't replace reading
books cover to cover the way i love to
do but for example with everything going
on right now with roe v wade i wanted
more of a detailed history of roe v wade
in the united states so on blinkist i
was able to get a 15-minute condensed
audio book of the mary ziegler book
abortion and the law in america roe v
wade to the present and in 15 minutes i
get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so it's
not to replace reading it's in addition
to for me you get the key takeaways from
blinkist from the books i would
certainly otherwise miss out on you can
try blinkist for free for seven days and
get a 25 percent discount off of a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below